e
e e
at 5:32 we'll call the meeting to
order number two the approval of the
minutes from January 15
2025 do I have the write one up here
yeah nice I'll change that I also just
wanted to add that I did make two
amendments to the original minutes you
should have gotten the most recent ones
this afternoon the two amendments were
to add the um times to the um call to
order and adjournment and the making of
uh northwater Street consist in both the
um the title and the
section um I'd actually like to make a
motion just to amend one more thing yes
um I would appreciate if we could more
quote when I made comments about the
demolition that I reflected on uh
Langer's history and demolition for the
sake of progress um
yeah that that's
all so am I missing something here in wh
in which section uh it would be
5A thank
you but actually with that uh
instead of motioning just to amend that
all motion to make that Amendment and
approve the minutes
simultaneously
okay I will second that we have a motion
on the floor and a second uh with the
proper Amendments of 5A and also the
change of the date
2025 January 15
2025 ready for the
question all in favor let it known by
saying
I I I I I I oppos hearing none eyes have
it motion
Carry Three uh subdivision and Land
Development a uh waiver of Land
Development uh 32 North Water
Street table from January to
15 and so this you received um via
packet the additional information
including the site plan and then I also
sent along today some updated
plans
Steve Steve is here if you have
questions oh yes I sure can the mic
any specific questions you want me to to
kind of answer I'm not sure exactly the
conversation last you state your name
please Steve Young thank
you Mr young one of the questions I had
I was looking at the plan and I know
there's one with a little bit more
detail that was also sent to us um what
are we looking at for egress or maybe
windows on the um apartment side sure
yes so the egress is g to and I had done
the original just hand drawing um
architect's kind of been working through
um what she's doing there so the access
to the apartments is along West Grant
Street so a few years back I had done um
the development of 30 northwater Street
and that was creating micro Apartments
commercial on the first floor by doing
that we you know dug down excavated to
be able to to provide Ada access for
that building um So the plan with these
other apartments so 32 it's 32 and 34
northw Street it's just deed Wise It's
called 32 um so lster galleries um Joy
recently retired so I bought the
building years back um so our agreement
was once she retired I was just going to
develop the back part of that so the
front part of it is staying commercial
and then the rear part is um this
Warehouse piece that was added I'm
guessing probably in the 60s or
something like that it used to be
friendly taxi had they would drive in
from the street and just work on their
taxis in the back which is kind of
interesting and unique for sure um so
ultimately to get access to those we're
going to use the current Ada ramp which
has um the level Air at the bottom there
so based on um calculations it's about 3
in difference to be able to um ramp up
to the um concrete Warehouse floor which
is why you see that cut in you know
there inside the door that we're going
to create there so right now we have
mini split HVAC so we're just going to
move those over and just extend the
entrance you know into that warehouse at
that Pro
property um so as far as Windows there
are a few um small Windows around the
sides of the warehouse um so um as we
kind of work through that we're figuring
out if egress windows are necessary um
and previously in the past there had
been about eight skylights as part of
the roof structure there um so we're
going to look to add those as well so to
get the natural light into the
apartments
can I ask a couple questions sure we
have this is all on the first level
correct all first level yeah so these
are all be Ada accessible apartments and
the you're going to be using the ramp
that currently Services 30 North correct
yes and then is are you going to make
them one parcel or is it I'm sorry say
that again make 30 and 32 34 one parcel
how will you maintain that um so I mean
technically the ramp parcel is on a
different LLC that I own it was part of
the property at 210 West Grand Street
when I purchased that so we just shaved
off a little bit of those parking spaces
to be able to create that ramp um so in
that process there wasn't actually
anything required since I had owned all
of those collectively so um I mean I
guess whatever easement wise or whatever
is necessary you know for that yeah I
think that's simple enough I was going
to say just in the event that you never
own all the parcels definitely getting
an easement recorded for Access would be
pretty important because otherwise sell
one building and next thing you know all
your tenants are like I can't get into
the apartment sure yeah now that makes
sense yeah I would also suggest um
contacting uh the engineer for separate
addresses for the apartments
sure uh I'm going to Echo a little bit
of what Mr whan had said about like just
windows I I know you said you're
evaluating I hope in your evaluation you
can determine um I I understand
especially with the middle Apartments it
can be a challenge maybe to find light
because they don't even have a wall wall
access but um you know light keeps
people happy uh regulated so anything
you can do to make sure your t7 after
the light I appreciate yeah no so the
the warehouse kind of encompasses the
footprint of the building or the
property as well so what we had done on
30 North water is um since that's on the
property line too we were able to get
fireproof glass to be able to do windows
so it's actually technically part of the
wall structure um so I mean not cheap
but I mean it's a way to get natural
light you know into any of the
apartments that we were
doing the only real question I have
because you answered the the question SL
concern I had the last meeting which was
um the commercial space because it's on
Water Street with the bike lane correct
on the not to bike Lanes do you have any
uh bike parking at your facilities
around here so there is um at 210 West
Grand Street we have a built-in um bike
parking and then at 30 northw Street we
had like a bike rack you know set up so
I mean it's kind of not bolted down but
I mean it's available for bike parking
got it
okay and I had had spoken to jam about
that
so I'm just curious about the size of
these apartments um so right around 400
square fet or so so um you know the
warehouse itself that's what we're just
kind of working through Dimensions um so
the warehouse itself is about 2400
square feet um so she was showing these
at a little over 400 so which is like 16
so I mean I figure there's probably
square footage somewhere that just
wasn't calculated but you know studio
type apartment so nothing below the
minimums that the city
requires yeah I mean I think this is a
great project and you know whenever we
can add housing units especially at that
size yeah I mean the ability to be able
to get ada8 units I mean it's just
nothing it's usually on a developer's
mind you know unfortunately
so you know we like to be able to to do
that where we can for sure
I'd like to make a motion to approve
then the waiver
request I'll also
second we have a motion on the
floor to approve the
waiver um what is that for
34 North
32 um North Water Street
and 30 and 30 nor Water
Street I think it's just
32 okay got
it you ready for the
question all in favor let it known by
saying I I I I I I oppos hearing none
eyes have it motion
carry thank you
so where's our
agenda I don't have my
paper oh yeah sorry
yeah
okay
B waiver of uh footprint
th thorough thres
threshold uh requirement for minor plan
618 South Prince
Street just introduce yourself yes uh
good afternoon my name is Dave kener I'm
the project
engineer uh on this project for new
person Ministry
are there any
questions
y yeah I do have a question so just
reading the text of our agenda um I saw
it was a conversion but then I also saw
like a demolition so I'm just a little
confused on if we're converting a
building or if we're tearing a building
down and using its
footprint yeah good question so um the
existing building is a just a block
building pretty generic uh it was a
storage building M and um so it's going
to be
um they had determined they can't really
use the the the block structure for
residential purposes so they're tearing
it down to the foundation and then
rebuilding it to fit
into the the housing it's on either side
so um
that's the
plan and so the ask of the commission is
to wave the threshold
requirement it suits a minor plan in all
ways other than the square footage and
so the request is to allow the extra
square footage and to enable this plan
to move forward as a minor if it is not
approved as a waiver to put it into the
minor it throws this plan into a regular
Land Development and so it is still
going to go through the full Land
Development process just only as a minor
plan that's what the waiver is for okay
I appreci it's not waving it out of a
minor plan it's waving it in to a minor
plan and it both happen so I understand
that's why I wanted to make this clarify
well I appreciate that because I I was a
little confused at first it read to me
like we were um waving any plan process
and you know if it was a conversion of a
building that was existing I think I'd
be amendable with that but because it's
a tear down rebuild I'd like to Le see
it as a no no there a minor plan is
going to move forward it just it because
it it goes to all of the other standards
of a minor plan except this one he's
asking for your approval to allow it to
proceed as a minor plan as opposed to a
regular Land
Development might be worth mention men
in that it had been the plan had been
before the historic U board and um we
also went through zoning to extend uh to
uh into the rear yard set back we needed
a little bit more space there for the
plan to work so they um yeah we made
that request of the Zoni hearing board
which they
approved at least you're on top of
it I mean actually with that
clarification I do feel Comfort
comfortable enough to say all I'll I'll
make a motion for this waiver to approve
this uh waiver into a minor plan
process
second I have a motion on the floor to
approve this a to a minor plan at six 18
South Prince
Street ready for a
question all in favor let it known by
saying I I I I I I oppose hearing none
uh eyes haveit motion
carry thank you for your time
sure four staff report to Planning
Commission um just a couple of quick
notes uh for today one I wanted to give
an update on the East End small area
plan I'm happy to report that we had a
very successful project team meeting um
last week um and we were able to share
the um our our consultant came and
shared a
PowerPoint presentation that covered our
existing conditions plan the plan the
existing conditions report I should say
it's 77 pages and she was able to bring
it down to like 14 slides and so much
more digestible um and it just gave a
nice overview of what all is included in
the existing conditions report and then
um we are now in the process of trying
to get that report the 77 Pages out to
the um the project team we're struggling
with the size of the file and having to
break it into several pieces and then
get it loaded somewhere where all of the
project team members will be able to
comment on it because not everybody has
that version of Adobe where you can
comment and so we are we're working on
it but also we have the state the city
last night and so Monday and Tuesday
nobody was working on it and so we're
getting there
um and so that we also talked about um
beginning um public engagement and so
last night at the state of the city
address I had a table that's he joined
me and we had um the survey we've
created the the online survey and a QR
code so we had a handout that had the QR
code on it to begin um Gathering
Community engagement through the survey
um I'm also going to go and have a table
at a public works event um about the
East End connector which is going to go
right near mcy which is also going to
cut through the East End and so I'll
also have a table there I'm hoping also
to go and speak with um the parent
organization at masasi and so trying to
hit that area um particularly people who
who have students who are walking and
biking to school so that of course mcy
campus has all three it has elementary
middle and high school right in that
area so it's a really important area for
us to hit um and so things are moving
along nicely um it took us a while but I
think that we're we're on the move and
should be seeing some good Community
engagement come early
spring um so that's up for the East End
PL and then for the train station I know
somebody had asked about that the the
last time that we had a meeting and so
just as a a very brief update we did
also have a meeting for that and I think
that the most important thing to know is
for right now going forward the first
piece of it that is being worked on is
the transportation piece and so there's
a lot of rope work that's going to need
to be done for that plan and it's going
to involve a lot of coordination between
the city and Manheim Township and pendon
and all of those intersections um that
are going to need a lot of work and a
lot of restructuring and um there's
going to be a lot of negotiating with
regard to you know how pendat indis
fixing the roads versus how Manheim or
the city envisions fixing the roads so
just kind of coming to the table and
figuring out how that's going to work
and who's going to lead all of that is a
big piece of where we are right now
we're working with the county so um
sitting at the table right now is the
county and Manheim and the city Alliance
um and of course the city and so
everybody's there to try to figure out
how to how to make it all work together
cooperatively and so that is where that
plan
is anybody else have any questions about
projects for
me I just will add real quick that the
pedestrian bridge over the track looks
like that's that construction of that is
started which is exciting oh that's it
that's great run past there
this thanks
ber anything
else other
business uh yeah we got a lot of time so
I'll figure I'll just kind of informally
be like hey let's talk a little bit
about the comp plan stuff um I was
curious if it would be possible to get
me a GIS file of our existing zoning map
um because I'd like to work up just some
general conceptual like just totally
theoretical maps of uh what things might
look like um but I I really don't want
to rebuild the map so I'm hoping that
the city has a file they can share with
me with any redactions to private
information of course um um and so
that's like a request to staff but
generally I'm just curious how you guys
feel um you know we have a lot of zoning
districts I forget how many exactly but
like more than a dozen which is a lot uh
I'm curious how many zoning districts do
you guys feel is appropriate because I'd
like to see a
reduction so I can work on getting you
the gis file um I would maybe caution
you not to go
outside of the Realms of a committee
when we go through the zoning process um
because all of that would be explored in
the committee portion of it um obviously
having ideas of what you want to what
you think should happen would be good I
do believe the comp plan includes a
reduction in the number of zoning
districts and kind of consolidation so
we are looking at that at the next
Planning Commission meeting look very
loud um at the next Planning Commission
meeting I'm going to kind of present the
timeline that we're looking for to go
through the zoning ordinance process
update process um and I can also provide
um a implementation plan that we have
for 2025 um we're working on that right
now um for the comp plan
so okay like the high priority a record
State you name dis yeah Betsy Logan I'm
the planning bureau
chief yeah I guess that was so thank you
um no I recognize that I'm just one
person on the bottom
but I I am definitely the type of person
who likes to throw ideas out there for
just general consumption and I love
making Maps yeah and the zoning map
doesn't have anything um like that layer
doesn't have anything like personal data
or anything like that on it so
okay uh bet yes sorry question for you
um yeah looking forward to the update in
uh our next meeting I'm curious also as
as you know you're kind of thinking
about implementation plan like are there
pieces that Planning Commission can help
with and could could that be part of uh
the presentation like if there are
things that you want us to start working
on when we have time or is this do you
see this as mostly just like you staff
driven and we you know can advise that
that's a great question I don't know
that I've worked that out yet um and I
think it really depends there's a couple
different ways that the zoning um
process can occur whether it's like
through a steering committee that is
supported by the planning commission
like members from there and other
agencies or boards and commissions would
be part of or if it's the Planning
Commission that's the steering committee
and it goes from there so I think um as
part of our scope we're going to include
that as a recommendation that we want to
see from the consultant um on how they
how they would recommend proceeding so
we're working I've got a draft scope
prepared I'm um in the process of trying
to finalize an RFP because we'll need a
consultant to kind of lead this process
since it's it's a big big
undertaking I would definitely say with
the staff blessing as well as with our
chair's blessing um I think it would be
a great idea to float or perhaps muster
ahead of time um any subcommittee
interest or steering committee interest
in that because when you're ready to
pull someone like Tony or whoever else
would be interested in it um then you
have us ready to go I would not be
opposed at all to floating that idea in
front of the um people who are here
today and have it noted for the people
who aren't here today who might be
interested in that because I think
there's a lot of interest in helping
helping with that because it's a it's an
enormous task right it is
y a lot of eyes are needed on it too and
so so you said we're we're going to be
doing an RFP to hire a consultant for
the uh zoning review or zoning change
process then correct y okay and I'll
just say for the record that yeah
there's a steering committee I think
I've expressed a lot of interest in
being on that
gotcha I also it's a great opportunity
for the Planning Commission to interact
with the zoning hearing board as well
because they they definitely need to be
at the table for any talk we have about
zoning so I think anytime you can talk
with them work with them have a you know
beneficial relationship uh because there
are municipalities for that is not not
always the case for sometimes the
Planning Commission the zoning hearing
board don't always pull in the same
direction so I think that would be key
to making a lot of these zoning changes
in reality yeah I would say um I would
want to run that by our solicitor just
because in the past I've had comment
from other solicitors that you don't
want zoning hearing boards involved in
the actual zoning process because I mean
obviously they can provide feedback and
their residents so they could be
involved in that aspect um just so that
you kind of keep that separate ation of
you know um but we will definitely
consider the kind of variances that have
been approved we have a database of that
um what the consist like consistently is
getting asked for and requested so that
we can try to fix those in the ordinance
um but yeah I think it's good to have a
zoning hearing board member at least
involved but I've also had feedback that
it's not the best option
so that'll have to be worked out
any further
questions thank you thank
you public
participation hearing
none do I have a motion to adjourn the
meeting let's go Motion to adjourn
second I have a
[Music]
motion yeah a second and a second sorry
for a question all in favor let it know
by saying I I I I I I post hearing none
I have it a meeting
adjourned at
60 on the DOT